I'm very grateful for that friendship it
did provide me a lot of comfort in those
really challenging years Jeanette
McCurdy's thinking her iCarly co-star
Miranda Cosgrove for helping her heal
from past trauma
while chatting with the ladies of red
table talk Jada Willow and Gammy the 30
year old actress opens up about how
Miranda helped her deal with her issues
with women amid a very complicated
relationship with her own mom my
relationship with Miranda was hugely
healing to my concept of women and my
mom was always saying men will never
really know you and they'll hurt you but
women will know you deeply and then
they'll hurt you you tell me which is
worse I have three brothers who I love
and I felt this sort of trust toward
boys that I didn't feel toward girls of
course very young and Miranda helped me
to heal that relationship but it is
something that I still struggle with and
that long time friendship continues to
impact Jeanette's life I made you a
sandwich
oh my God I love Miranda to pieces I
always will she has such a special place
in my heart she helped me
grow as a person and heal as a person
and I hope I did the same for her and I
just love her so much we totally still
keep in touch not as often as we used to
we used to be attached to the hip so it
was very it was very much that kind of
relationship throughout honestly
probably until our mid-20s but now we're
all uh we're all grown up in our
different directions but I'm always
rooting for her Jeanette goes into
detail about the emotional and physical
abuse she says she endured from her late
mother Deborah McCurdy in her Memoir I'm
glad my mom died it was a difficult
reality to come to terms with but
something that I did through years of
therapy
um certainly it was important for me to
explore all that personally before
exploring it creatively or in any sort
of a public-facing way I really needed
to understand and make sense of my past
privately and on my own time which I did
and uh and I'm proud of that work and at
the red table the former Nickelodeon
star shares an example of just how rough
things got here's Jeanette reading an
email from her mom after discovering
Jeanette was dating Harley Rider Paul
Glaser a man more than a decade older
than her
dear net I am so disappointed in you you
used to be my perfect little angel but
now you are nothing more than a little
all-caps [ __ ] uh floozy all used up and
to think you wasted it on That Hideous
ogre of a man I told your brothers about
you and they all said they disown you
just like I do we want nothing to do
with you love Mom or should I say Deb
since I'm no longer Your Mother P.S send
money for a new fridge ours broke
Jeanette's fractured relationship with
her mom compels Jada to ask do you think
you want to have children of your own oh
Jada I was thinking the same thing get
out of my head I would never want to
have a child for my own identity that's
a very very concrete yeah one for me I'm
in a place where so I'm 30. I don't feel
like I want kids I have two nieces that
I adore and a third on the way I'm
really happy to be an aunt and right now
I don't feel that I want them but I'm
also open open to maybe a couple years
from now or whatever I I something hits
me and I just feel like yeah I do want
that um but for now from there you're
good yes
echoing all that Jeanette told E.T last
month she feels like she's exactly where
she needs to be have you found that
woman that you are and that you want to
be I have from both I think you know a
value standpoint and a and a personal
standpoint as well as a professional one
um professionally I'd like to focus on
writing and directing I'm writing a
novel and writing a collection of essays
I'm doing what I would like to be doing
what's the novel about uh I'm not
talking about it yet okay that'll be I
guess another Tour all right this is day
one of this book so we're gonna have to
wait yeah exactly
[Music]
thank you